I have ongoing regret for never joining
the military or police department and
I'm not yet strong enough to consider
changing careers now for financial
reasons I also don't know how to discuss
this with my wife as we want to make
some additions to the family soon
I feel unfulfilled in the single aspect
of my life it's a strange feeling
considering I have skyrocketed up the
chain in my company so quickly so many
would do anything to be where I find
myself how do you overcome your face or
how do you overcome or face yourself
knowing you're holding back from a
certain calling because I really do see
it as a calling in some form I'm
interested to hear from you I think this
is pretty easy go join the reserves go
join the reserves be going the army
reserves go in there like every branch
has some reserves where you gonna do one
weekend a month you have to do boot camp
that'll be whatever it's gonna be 10
weeks 12 weeks 14 weeks depending on
which branch you go into and then you do
one weekend a month and you do two weeks
in the summer you you'll understand what
the military is about there's actually a
chance well first of all there's chance
you'll be deployed I mean when we were
in Iraq you know when we deployed to
Ramadi my second deployment to Iraq the
the unit that was there the two to eight
iron soldiers they were reserve unit out
of Pennsylvania they were awesome and
they'd been there for 14 months and they
lost a lot of guys and they fought hard
so it's not like this reservists thing
is is is a different class a soldier
they're soldiers for real they're
Marines for real and you may be going on
deployment but what's cool about it is
most companies they will excuse you
basically when you go in the reserves
they'll excuse you when you have time I
fact I think it's I was never in the
reserves but I think you're actually
protected by the federal government from
being fired because you're serving in
the reserves so I would definitely go
and look into the reserves because
otherwise that feeling that you have I
can only imagine it's never gonna go
away I don't know because I had that
feeling that I wanted to join the
military when I was
four years old and I didn't assumes that
turned 18 so I don't you know I you know
what I regret now I was like I want to
still be in huh you know so especially
now with the fighting picking up
overseas it's uh you know that's that's
the only thing that that I feel is damn
I want to go back but if you never did
it at all that's a grinding feeling so
go talk to a recruiter getting the
reserves and you know what else in
certain areas there's definitely
volunteer fire departments yeah you can
volunteer as a fireman then you can
volunteer as a policeman there have
certain I don't have no idea what state
you're from asking this question but
there's deputies you can get deputized
you can go through a in San Diego they
definitely have reserved cops where you
have to go to you have to go to the the
police academy and you become a reserve
cop so and with all that you want to
talk about it with your wife talk about
with your wife yeah you know you say you
don't know how to this isn't a situation
where you can be totally honest with her
hey I always want to join the military I
haven't done it I feel like it's
something I really want to do here's the
options I want to go look at what do you
think now you're you're marrying you
married to a girl and you're gonna have
kids
it's your military service will be
harder on her than it is on you so she
better be strong she better be tough and
you know them the military wives out
there I mean my wife when I was gone on
deployment after deployment it's it's
not easy I mean luckily she's tough and
she raised kids without me and she took
care of household without me and she
went to the hospital to visit my wounded
guys and she went to the funerals of my
guys we were getting killed and she had
to do that while I was gone on
deployment and I was she was hearing for
me once a week maybe so you're gonna put
your family through a lot of stress
now you might stress your family a lot
by always having regret that they held
you back that's selfish but that's true
so I would just go look into it see what
the options are talk about it with your
wife there are some really good benefits
to it and also the final point is
sometimes when you're
reservists you can decide that you want
to go active duty maybe you love it
maybe you say yeah this was my card
maybe your fourth day in boot camp where
you haven't slept you had your head
shaved you're tired you're hungry the
food is horrible and you say man this is
what I've always wanted to do with my
life and if that happens there's options
where you can now go active duty and and
you can see how your wife dealt with it
while you were gone and if she dealt
with it well that's great hey let's make
a career out of this and that's a good
option to do so there's some I think
you're this is this is this is easy day
easy easy problem to take care of mmm no
factor